[Musique]
c'est toi que j'aime je sais
reconnaissez-vous avoir poignardé damien
joly aujourd'hui à 13h47
pourquoi j'ai fait ça donc ça s'arrête
j'ai tellement j'ai envie de vivre avec
toi je vais faire j'ai vu l'enfant s'est
gelé vu la détruire petit à petit
[Musique]
c'est quand même un peu con si du cul
il faisait la misère est revenu à chaque
fois
pardon j'ai l'intimé conviction qu'il
l'a détruite j'ai vraiment besoin de
votre aide
est ce que vous avez perdu des choses
pendant cette relation si des amis
mon boulot on est partenaire
monfils aussi j'ai parti qu'est ce que
c'est
le propre d'un pervers en fait c'est de
pousser jusqu'au suicide j'ai
l'impression d'être face à une victime
qu'autre chose
d'ici septembre
découvrez la création exclusive m6 à la
folie
[Musique]
ce programme sera disponible en
audiodescription